ونحييكم الى تفاصيل اكد وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الله خلال زيارته
لتركيا عن ترحيبه بالتقارب بين سوريا من
جهه وتركيا من جهه اخرى وقال عبد الله
هيان في حديث الصحفيين قبيله مغادرته
طهران متوجها الى انقره قال انه كان من
المقرر وبحسب برنامج زيارته التوجه الى
موسكو الا ان هذه الزياره تاجلت لي بعض
الوقت وسيتوجه الى تركيا ويرى المراقبون
ان هدف ايران من زياره وزير الخارجتها
لتركيا هو تقديمه رساله مبطنه لروسيا التي
تفعل لتحقيق مصلحه تركيه السوريه لتجاهلها
طهران وابعادها وتحجيمرها
وموقعها عن هذا الحدث في حين يرى البعض
الاخر انها طهران اليوم باتت قلقه من هذا
التقارب بالواسطه الروسيه في خطوه يمكن ان
تزيد من نفوذ موسكو على حسابين نفوذها هي
في دول جوارها وهذا ما لا تريد طهران
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي نعمل لندن
عارف نصرالبحث في شان الايراني ومن موسكو
بسام البني الكاتب السياسي اهلا بكم
ابدا من لندن معك يا استاذ عارف حتى ناخذ
بدايه قراءه للجنب الايراني او كيف تفكر
ايران البعض يقول بان الرياح جرت بما لا
تشتهي طهران فتم استثناؤها من لقاء موسكو
ما اربكها واربكا حسبتها الحاليه كيف ترى
الموضوع
تحيه طيبه
والمشاهدينكم الكرام مضيفكم الكريم ايضا
فيما يتعلق بالدور
التقارب التركي السوري في ما يبدو بانه
هنالك ثلاثه خطوط عريضه الجانب الاول ربما
يتعلق بالرؤيه الايرانيه الاستراتيجيه
للخطبه اسرائيليه بمعنى ان الخطه
باسرائيليه اذا ما ارادت ان تنفذ عمليات
فانها تعتمد على تحيد سوريا تحيد سوريا من
همم
ربما ان تلعب دور بهذا بهذه الخطه وخاصه
ونحن نعلم بان ايران خلال السنوات الماضيه
عمدت على نصب مضاد مضادات للطائرات وكذلك
رادارات كثيره في كثير من المناطق
السوريات جانب الثاني هنالك اا ربما همم
طمع ايراني ان تلعب دور باعاده اعمار
سوريا خاصه وانها تكلف اكثر من 600 مليار
دولار كما تفيد بعض التقارير التي
هالنظام الايراني والنقطه الثالثه هي ان
تكون ضمن اليه اللعبه السياسيه والجانب
السياسي خاصه واحنا نعلم بان بعد الحرب
همم
الاوكرانيه عمليا ايران استطاعت ان تلعب
دور اكبر هذا ما لم يرته الجانب الروسي
لذلك تم ابعاد فيما يبدوا ايران من هذا
الدور وهذا ما لا يريده الجانب استاذ بس
ما رايك لان الباص كذلك يرى في ان انا
امام همم
تشوش علاقه بين حالتين ايران اليوم تزود
موسكو بالطائره المسيره وقد تعرض ايراني
لمزيد من العقوبات والمزيد من تورطها في
هذه الحرب همم
لماذا موسكو عمدت الى استثناء ايران من
هذه اللقاءات
اسعد الله مسائكم مسائكم الكريم ومساء
مشاهدين قناه العربيه الكرام اولا يعني في
ظل
التنافس على النفوس في سوريا بين ايران
وسوريا وروسيا وتركيا هناك ايضا التنسيق
بين الضامنين الثلاثه لمسار استنا ولا
اعتقد ان روسيا استبعدت ايران لان روسيا
اليوم مصلحه في ايران عن طريق عن من من
بسبب الطريق الذي تفتحه روسيا من روسيا
الى الهند عن طريق بحر قزوين وايران هذه
نقطه النقطه الاخرى هناك التعاون العسكري
التقني بين ايران وروسيا اضيف الى ذلك ان
ايران ترحب كما قال ضيفكم الكريم بهذا
التقرب من بين دمشق انقره لان التوافق بين
دمشق وانقره يعني فك الحصار الاقتصادي عن
دمشق وبالتالي تحسين الوضع المعيشي
للمواطنين هما يساهم في تنفيذ حل سياسي
يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى ارجاع جزء او لم
ناكل يعني كل اللاجئين فبالتاكيد جزء من
اللاجئين السوريين في تركيا الامر الذي
يساعد اردوغان في الانتخابات القادمه ما
يعني اننا امام عمليه اعاده توزيع للادوار
وضبط للساعات حول ما يجري بين دمشق وانقره
لا اعتقد ان اي خلاف موجود بين ايران
وروسيا ولا بين ايران وسوريا
وتركيا بشان سوريا الخلافات قد ايه يعني
قد تكون نحو المصالح يعني هناك ممكن يكون
مصالح مشتركه نعم الدول ليست جمعيات خيريه
وايران في سوريا ليس لعيون السوريين ولا
على سواد عيونهم وتركيا ايضا ليس على سواد
عيون السوريه ولا حتى اضيف ولكن هناك
مصالح دوليه ولكن انا الاحظ ان المصالح
اليوم تصب في مصلحه
ااا الاطراف يعني بين ايران وروسيا هناك
مصالح وبين تركيا وروسيا هناك مصالح وهذه
المصالح تفوق عن التنافس الذي يحدث في
سوريا
او قد تخلط الامور استاذه بسام يعني حتى
وان كانت الواجهه همم تدل على ان العلاقات
تمشي بطريقه عاديه ولكن الشيطان يكون في
التفاصيل وهون سؤال سيد عارف تقول منذ
قليل بان همم الساحه الروسيه قد تكون محطه
مشاكل للجهتين بان موسكو لا تود ان ترى
توسع عن النفوذ الايراني في داخل سوري
ولكن ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه موسكو او ما
الاجراءات التي يمكن ان تطرحها لي
وقف تمدد ايران في سوريا
الواقع هنالك الكثير من اللقاء ساعود لك
استاذ بسام سؤال سيد عارف تفضل يعني
النقطه الاساسيه التي يمكن ان نقف عندها
هي تكمن بالنظره الروسيه الى ايران عمليا
انا اعتقد بان لا يوجد نظره الى ان ايران
هي حليف استراتيجي الى الجانب الروسي
هنالك ممكن اعتبار ان الجانب الروسي يرى
بايران نصف حليفن صح التعبير
بل في احيان كثيره وخاصه في قضيه همم
استخدام الوسيرات الايرانيه هنالك حتى
عمليه توريق ونحن عمليا بالملف النووي
الايراني نتذكر همم بان كيف الجانب الروسي
همم ربما همم بمرات كثيره اعاق عمليه
الوصول الى اتفاق نووي بعد ما كان العالم
يتركب خلال ايام ان ان يتم الاتفاق لذلك
فيما يبدو
النظره الروسيه لايران هي نظره لا تكمن
ليست ايجابيه بكل الاحوال ويمكن اعتبارها
ورقه لصالح مصالحها وبكل الاحوال المصالح
التي تكون ايضا بين رؤوس روسيا والجانب
الاسرائيلي اقوى بكثير من التي تجمع ايران
وروسيا من هنا في ما يبدو بان الكثير من
الملفات الامنيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
تمنع الجانب
الروسي ان يعتمد على التمدد الايراني
بالمنطقه لكن كيفيه ااه ربما ما هي همم
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه فانا اعتقد بان ربما
هنالك الكثير من الطرق التي هو الكثير من
الاوراق التي يمكن ان يستخدمها الجانب
الروسي احداها هذا الاتفاق وربما تعزيز
الدوره التركي همم في سوريا ولكن من
النقاط الاخرى
بسام وهنا سؤال حظرتك همم ليست تفاصيل همم
العلاقه العلاقه المتوتره لم يعرفها البعض
فقط بالاستناد على ما يحصل في سوريا على
ساحه السوريه ولكن كذلك على تصريحات ايران
التي تحدثت فيها بطريقه الهجوم على تركيا
همم تقول بان تركيا تحاول التشويش على
حدودها همم التي القريبه من دول القوقاز
وبالتالي هذا كذلك موضوع مطروح وفي ادماج
تركيا في همم همم حوارات ثلاثيه قد لا
يرضي ايران كذلك هذا الموضوع
يعني بكل تاكيد هناك خلافات ايضا بين
روسيا وبين ايران من جهه وبين روسيا وبين
تركيا من جهه اخرى حول تمدد التركي على
سبيل المثال في منطقه القوقاز وما يسمى
العالم التركي وهناك خلافات بين روسيا
وايران بما تقوم به من اعمال لا تعجب
روسيا اضف الى ذلك روسيا لا تنسى يعني انه
عندما حصل الاتفاق النووي بين ايران
والاداره الامريكيه اول ما تضرر في
الشركات الروسيه وقد تم طرد شركات النفط
الروسيه من ايران عندها ولكن اليوم الوضع
تغير اليوم ايران وروسيا في خندق واحد
تجاه العقوبات الغربيه التي تقام من طرف
واحد ولهذا السبب نجد ان ايران هي شريك
مرحله اليوم لروسيا حسب وجهه نظري انا هو
شريك من اجل مرحله ان روسيا اليوم في حاله
اشتباك مع الغرب عسكريا على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه فلا اسم من مصلحه روسيا ان
تشتعل همم
وهات اخرى قد تضطر للدخول في صراعات اخرى
عسكريه تستنزفها ايضا لذلك روسيا تعمل على
موازنه الامور بين الشركاء والحلفاء
والذين يعني لا يلضمون الى العقوبات على
اقل تقدير التي تفرضها الغرب على روسيا
لهذا السبب نجد هذا التنسيق بين تركيا
وروسيا وايران على قدم وساق وخاصه بانهم
كانوا لهم تجربه ناجحه فيما يسمى مسار
السنه في دمشق حول حول سوريا يعني هذا
النقاط كلها يجب اخذها في عين الاعتبار
اضيف الى ذلك كما قلت لك في مداخله الاولى
هناك الخط الذي يوصل بين روسيا والهند عن
طريق بحرق قزوين وايران هناك تحويل تركيا
الى مركز لتوزيع الغاز هذا يعني انهم يعني
سواء تركيا او روسيا مع عباره عن رئه
لروسيا اليوم في ظل الحصار الذي يحاول
الفرده عليها هذه الاسماء كلها تؤدي
بالتالي ان روسيا لا تريد لا استفزاز
ايران ولا استفزاز تركيا في ازاله الوقت
وكما هم يعني روسيا بحاجه هاتان دولتان
ايضا هاتان الدولتان بحاجه روسيا بشكل
كبير للغايه فترك لديها ازمه اقتصاديه
ولديها ازمه انتخابات قادمه معركه بين
اردوغان والمعارضه وايران ايضا لديها
مظاهرات تقوم يقوم بها الاكراد ال- ال-
الايرانيون اضيفوا الى ذلك انها محاصره
ايضا من قبل الغرب هذا يضعنا امام مشهد
مثالي من اجل ايجاد حلول الوسط بين الاخوه
الاعداء انصحه التعليميه
استاذ عارف همم هل ترى بان كل هذه الاطراف
ستسعى لتصفير المشاكل في المنطقه او لا او
هناك اولويات قد تضع على طاوله ملفات
شائكه في الواقع همم قادره ان تشوش على
هذه العلاقات الثنائيه
الواقع بان هذا الامر مرتبط ايضا بما يجري
في ايران وكذلك المقال الذي عليها ربما
العلاقات او كيفيه
استثمار هذه العلاقات همم
على الجانب السوري خاصه بمحيطه العربي
وكذلك حتى ما يحدث ايضا في الداخل التركي
والانتخابات القادمه كل هذه الامور تلعب
دور مباشر ودور مهم ومصيري لكنما يجب ان
نشير الى نقطه مهمه وهي الى جانب ما تفضل
به ضيفكم الكريم على نقاط
الاتفاق الايرانيه الروسيه هنالك ايضا
نقاط تبعد همم جانب الروسي من الايراني
اهمها الصراع او المنافسه الشديده الان
باسواق النفط بين الجانب الروسي والجانب
الايراني خاصه وان بعض الاحصائيات الان
تشير بان ايران عرضت كميات كبيره اكثر من
مليون برميل يوميا باسعار زهيده جدا اقل
من السعر الذي يطرحه الجانب الروسي وهذا
ما اثار امتعاض الجانب الروسي اضافه الى
ذلك نحن نعلم بان ايران ايضا همم لم تزود
الجانب الروسي ببعض الصواريخ قصيره المدى
خوفا من العقوبات الغربيه وهذا ايضا فيما
يبدو بانه يشير الى ان الاتفاق همم
الروسيا الايراني ليس جامع وليس كامل
وهنالك ايضا بعض النغاط الخلافه التي همم
تعكر همم ربما هذه همم الرؤيه التي همم
لدى الطرفين استاذ بسام اخت معك وبصراحه
كما ترى الامور هل تعتقد بان موسكو تاخذ
همم حقيقه بعين الاعتبار مصالح ايران حتى
وان كنت ترى بان بانها حديث همم يعني وقتي
او مرحله كما تفضلت بالاشاره ولكن هل ترى
بان موسكو
عن اعتبار هذه المصالح او لا او ان لديها
اولويات
السبب الرئيسي حول الحرب في سوريا والتدخل
الايراني والتدخل التركي والتدخل الروسي
نجد هو خط الغاز الذي كان من المفروض ان
ينتقل من الحقل الشمالي للغاز الذي تستحق
تستطيع ايران وقطر الاستهلاك منه وهذا
الخط كان يجب ان يمر من سوريا ولكن بعد
التطبيع بعض الدول العربيه مع اسرائيل
اصبح من الممكن تمريره هذا الخط من غير
سوريا لهذا نجد ان تركيا اليوم تتقرب من
دمشق من اجل ان لا تمر هذا الخط من
اسرائيل وبالتالي قد تكون ايران قد يعني
ارتفعت حساسيتها زياده عن اللزوم من
التقارب بين دمشق وتركيا ولكن روسيا ليس
من مصلحتها هذا راي الشخصي بمرور هذا الخط
لا من لا عبر لايران ولا لقطر ولا لاي
دوله اخرى لانه يضر بمصالحها في نهايه
الامر والدول كما قلت لك ليست جمعيات
خيريه وروسيا تبحث عن مصالحها اكثر عن
المصالح
طلب في متابعه هذا الموضوع شكرا جزيلا على
المشاركه من لندن عارف ناصر البحث
الايراني هو من موسكو بسام البني الكاتب
اساسي شكرا لكما